Hey everyone, Ryan here and welcome back to our orthodontic series.
So in this video we are going to cover a lot of orthodontic appliances.
So I'm going to try to stick to the highest yield big picture facts associated with each
of these appliances.
So first let's talk about types of orthodontic treatment.
So while patient is young and growing, we can try to modify how their jaws are growing,
addressing an underlying skeletal discrepancy.
Now when the patient is older and has stopped growing, the only way to address a true skeletal
issue at its source is with surgical correction.
But the vast majority of treatment falls somewhere in the middle, either not taking teeth out
with non-extraction or taking teeth out with extraction, either way moving teeth around
within the jaws that you have.
So these are purely dental, alveolar changes.
And importantly, if there's an underlying skeletal discrepancy, either of these treatment
options is simply camouflaging the skeletal problem with dental change.
So I think this is a really helpful way, a big picture view of looking at the four main
categories of orthodontic treatment.
And we'll be focusing on the first three of these in this video.
So successful growth modification can only occur during periods of active growth.
And that's generally from 8 to 13 for girls and let's say 10 to 15 for boys.
But of course, there's individual variation there.
And this is really why we spent a whole video talking about growth and development because
it does come into play in the clinic in terms of when and how we can do growth modification.
So class 2 headgear restrains maxillary growth forward, functional appliances, stimulate
mandibular growth forward, and both of these are targeted towards class 2 patients.
And then we have reverse pull headgear, which stimulates maxillary growth forward.
And truthfully, there's really no good way to restrain mandibular growth, although a
chin cup has been used to attempt that.
And both of these are targeted towards helping class 3 patients.
So we're going to unpack each of these categories in the next several slides.
So headgear is best used during the ascending portion of the pubertal growth spurt.
Another way to say that is the patient is pre-pubertal.
And headgear can be used to modify growth of the jaws or sometimes to reinforce anchorage.
But again, we're going to be focusing on the growth modification piece.
And most of these should be worn preferentially 12 to 14 hours per day in order to hit that
threshold for an effect on the jaws.
So compliance is a huge issue with headgear.
High or occipital pull headgear involves a face bow that connects or hooks into headgear
tubes on the upper molar bands.
You have a head strap at the back of the head and then this elastic band that applies force.
And we can actually literally see that force vector that's being applied to the face bow
and indirectly to the teeth.
So what is this doing?
Well, it's restraining maxillary forward growth, but it's also having a dental effect.
And it's intruding and distalizing those upper molars thanks to that upward force vector.
And so it's best for class two open bite patients, class two because it's restraining maxillary
growth and open bite because it's intruding posterior teeth.
And if it's intruding posterior teeth, that helps to close a bite down in the front.
For a low or cervical pull headgear, that involves, again, a face bow and elastic band.
But this time, there's a neck strap, so the force vector is pointing down this time.
So we're going to restrain maxillary forward growth.
This time we're going to extrude and distalize those upper molars.
So this one's going to be best for class two deep bite patients because extruding posterior
teeth helps to open a bite in the front.
J-hook headgear looks kind of similar to the headgear we've already looked at.
But this time, a J-shaped hook engages into a loop in the arch wire, usually by the upper
lateral or canine.
So this provides extra oral anchorage to retract the canines and incisors and is most effective
in maximum anchorage cases.
So the target for this one is dento alveolar and it's actually not growth modification
in this case.
Reverse pull headgear is called such because it's pulling in the opposite direction.
We're not pulling back, we're actually pulling forward.
It's also sometimes called a face mask because it's located in front of the face.
So this is going to stimulate maxillary forward growth with that forward pull.
Other effects often undesirable include protraction of the upper incisors, retraction of the
lower incisors and clockwise rotation of the mandible.
Now it's best for class three patients with a deficient maxilla because it's really mostly
targeting the maxilla.
This treatment should be done really as soon as those permanent first molars and incisors
erupt and we want to do it really early on because we want those circummaxillary sutures,
the sutures around the maxilla to be as pliable and loose as possible.
So really we could do this as soon as age six to eight or soon after that.
So the chin cup involves extra oral force to the mandible anchored against the back of
the head and this is to restrain mandibular growth at the condyles.
So this has been shown to restrain mandibular growth in animal studies where monkeys would
wear the appliance for 24 hours a day but in humans this simply doesn't work.
And the result is instead of restraining mandibular growth, we're really getting clockwise and
open rotation of the mandible rather than true growth restraints.
So this one I say best and a loosely, it's best for class three mandibular excess patients
with the caveat that it doesn't really work all that well.
All right, the next category are the functional appliances.
And functional appliances like headgear are best used during the ascending portion of
the puberdal growth spurt and the idea is that they influence the normal function of
the mandible and these appliances posture the mandible into a protrusive position and
the resultant stretch of the facial muscles and soft tissue modify growth at the condyles
and you can feel that kind of stretch if you push your lower jaw forward.
So these are all class two correctors, particularly patients with a mandibular deficiency because
this time we're really focusing on that mandible.
So most of these functional appliances are removable.
So again, like headgear, patient compliance plays a major, major role.
So the biinator involves a horseshoe shaped acrylic that's located between the upper and
lower teeth and it guides the patient into a position where the mandible is advanced
forward so the lower teeth can clear this block of plastic.
In addition, this labial bow here anterior to the maxillary incisors tries to eliminate
pressure from the upper lip and buckle musculature.
So with the mandible being held forward, the thought is bone growth at the condyles is
going to be accelerated to fill in the extra space at the jaw joint.
The biinator has some pros, it's a simple design, it's fairly durable, has a lot of
hardware to keep all these pieces intact and it's generally readily accepted by patients.
The activator is similar is actually the first removable functional appliance developed and
the idea is very similar to the biinator that the activation of the mandibular musculature
is important in obtaining a growth effect.
The lingual flanges of this appliance design extend deeper than it does in the biinator
which encourages that forward posture to avoid this impinging on the floor of the mouth but
this also means it's generally less well received and more uncomfortable than the biinator is.
So a twin block can be fixed, it can be cemented in place or it can be removable like the previous
two and if it's fixed on the teeth, it can be cemented in place at the molars or sometimes
even the premolars.
If it's removable, it's retained on the teeth with conventional clasps as seen here.
So these plastic blocks on the upper and lower portions can be used to control eruption of
the teeth which gives you an added benefit.
You can try to block eruption of certain teeth if you're worried about vertical issues but
they also work as part of the functional appliance because they have these inclines.
So these inclines on the upper and lower blocks force the patient to advance the mandible
in order to close all the way.
You can imagine if this dentiform has an advanced all the way and this lower block is located
here, they're going to bang up against each other and the patient can't close together
which is a really uncomfortable feeling.
So that is essentially how the twin block works.
It forces you to protrude this mandible forward and you have some tension created soft tissue
pull and the oral musculature and then you have space back at the condyle and the thought
is it's accelerating bone growth at that condyle.
The pros of the twin block is that it provides more positive mandibular changes than the previous
two this is according to many class two studies that have been conducted in the literature.
The MARA is a mandibular anterior repositioning appliance, that's what it stands for and this
is a fixed appliance, it was created in the 1990s so this is actually a pretty recent and
it requires the patient to again advance their mandible in order to close otherwise the upper
elbow that's this part that's connected to the upper molar tube interferes with the lower
fixed arm.
So it's again very similar to the ones we've already talked about, you have to actively
advance the mandible in order to clear the interference and close all the way.
The pros with this one is it's less bulky, it's more durable and more stable than the
hertz appliance which is on the next slide.
The cons are that you get generally less mandibular advancement than the twin block which is what
we just talked about and the hertz which we'll talk about right now.
The hertz is another fixed appliance, this one was created in the early 1900s but it
was popularized later in the century.
So this time we have a piston and a tube device that can be adjusted when the patient comes
in for appointments and it literally pushes the mandible forward as the patient closes.
So this one is passively pushing the mandible forward.
The patient doesn't have to actively activate their muscles to close in that way.
The appliance is essentially doing the work for them.
So besides not breaking it, there's actually minimal compliance here because again the
appliance does all the work of advancing the mandible.
So forcing the patient to maintain an advanced mandibular position can generate both skeletal
and dental changes.
But keep in mind that all of these appliances while we want skeletal change, they're going
to produce some amount of dental change as well.
Typically, you're going to get some upper distal and intrusive force and lower intrusive
and mesial force.
You're also going to get some proclination of these lower incisors and retroclination
of these upper incisors.
That's kind of the classic class two mechanics in these functional appliances.
For the board exam, I wouldn't worry about all of those small minute details and focus
more on the big picture stuff, kind of like we've been talking about so far.
So I'm calling these two other class two correctors because, well, they're not really functional
appliances for growth modification.
Their effects are almost entirely dental alveolar.
I'd probably also put class two elastics or rubber bands in this category as well.
So the force's appliance is another fixed appliance and it's a push rod spring.
So this push rod can be assembled intraorally by attaching it to the headgear tube on the
upper molar and then to the lower arch wire by the premolar canine area.
And it's not going to get the same skeletal effect because it's not holding the mandible
forward.
It's not forcing you to push the mandible forward, but you do get similar tooth movement
effects in that there are upper intrusive and distalization forces and lower intrusion
and musial forces applied by the spring that's pushing in both directions.
The pros are it's non-compliant and doesn't require patient compliance other than not
breaking it, of course, and it's often the go-to if patients aren't wearing their elastics
properly.
More maxillary restriction, that's probably in relation to the Herpes appliance, which
you're theoretically getting more mandibular advancement than you are maxillary restriction.
As far as cons, it requires heavy upper and lower arch wires in order to avoid some more
undesirable side effects in terms of dental movements.
So you really need to have some pretty good arch wires to avoid some unwanted rotations
and things like that.
The pendulum appliance is a fixed appliance, although I have seen some versions that are
removable, and this one is banded to the upper first molars for the distalization and de-rotation
of those molars.
So you have this acrylic button on the pallet with wire rests that are bonded to the premolars
for anchorage, and then you have these helical springs that provide a light, continuous pressure
to push those molars back.
So that is a localized form of Class II correction at the molars.
You can also ask for a Pindex appliance that's pendulum and expander combined if you want
to use a jack screw expander for broadening that arch at the same time.
We'll cover expanders in just a little bit here.
In fact, let's cover in the next slide.
So you may be sensing a theme here, but palatable expanders are best used during the ascending
portion of the pubertal growth spurt.
Once again, while those sutures are pliable and growth is actively occurring.
So the Shwarz appliance is a removable appliance, and it has a jack screw located right here
at the midline between the left and the right plates.
Now with this kind of appliance, the patient's parent or guardian is responsible for taking
a small key that comes with the appliance and turning this jack screw.
And one turn is going to equal 0.25 or 1/4 of a millimeter of expansion.
So one turn is 0.25 millimeters, and so you may do one turn a day, you may do one turn
every other day, you may do two turns a day, depends how aggressive you want to expand.
Now the problem with this one is it's removable, so failure to wear the appliance, even for
just a day, might require adjustment of the jack screw in order to constrict it back the
other way until it fits the mouth, because this transverse expansion can relapse very
quickly, so even one day of not wearing it, it might not fit the next day.
With this appliance, you're really only getting dental tipping, that's tipping of these teeth
out, and you're not really getting true skeletal expansion at the mid-palatal suture, especially
if you're using this in the lower arch, because mandibular skeletal expansion is impossible,
because there's no suture in the mandible, so a lower source especially will only accomplish
dental tipping.
This appliance is only realistically good for treating mild posterior cross-pights.
The W arch, because it looks like a W, is a fixed appliance, and this one's banded to
the molars, so you get this compressed spring that's activated when you push it into the
mouth.
So really, it's looking something more like this, and when we go to squeeze it in there,
we have to squeeze those arms so they're activated and they're delivering pressure to the right
and to the left.
It's delivering a few hundred grams of force and provides slow expansion, so generally
pretty light force in terms of skeletal expansion, so you're realistically getting about one-thirds
skeletal expansion and two-thirds dental expansion, but once again you're getting mostly dental
tipping but a little bit more skeletal expansion than the schwarz plate.
It's more effective and more comfortable and generally more efficient than that split plate
or schwarz appliance.
The quad helix is another fixed appliance, and it's named because there are four helical
loops.
We have one here, two, three, and four, so two in the anterior and two in the posterior.
It's similar to the W arch, is it still kind of looks like a W, but it's capable of applying
force more to the anterior or more to the posterior depending on how it's activated thanks
to these four loops.
So if you activate the front ones more, you're going to get more posterior expansion.
If you activate the posterior ones more, you're going to get more anterior expansion, so it
just depends on how you choose to activate those loops.
If it's in for a long time, it's kind of interesting, both the W arch and the quad helix can actually
leave an imprint on the dorsal surface of the tongue.
So the high racks is one of the more common expanders used today.
It's another fixed appliance, and the bands are usually cemented on the molars, the first
molars, as well as the first premolars.
Again, this is involving a jack screw expander right here at the center, and one turn each
day is enough to produce up to a hundred newtons of force and expand the pallet effectively
by opening that mid-palatal suture.
You can really tell that that suture is opening up when you see a diastema between eight and
nine opening up as well.
So the pros of this one are you're going to get, you will get effective skeletal expansion,
as well as that patient is at the right age.
Cons are, it's bulky, it's more difficult to place and remove because of it.
The patient also may have trouble cleaning, so it can lead to some real bad soft tissue
irritation of the pallet, and the patient or parent must activate the appliance.
So again, we're depending on compliance, whereas with the quad helix and W arch, this
bent wire does all the work for us.
The high racks, any kind of jack screw appliance, we have to depend on the parent and guardian
doing the key turning.
Ahaz is the same as the high racks.
It's a fixed appliance with a jack screw expander, except it has two big acrylic pads
that contact the palatal mucosa, which some clinicians feel maximizes that skeletal expansion.
Because these pads are contacting the palatal tissue, so you're getting this tissue-borne
effect, not just a tooth-borne appliance like with the high racks.
The problem is, this one can be really hard to keep clean, and so you can get some really
nasty tissue when you take this thing out.
A whole bunch of food and stuff caught above this appliance is not a fun time.
So with TPA or a trans palatal arch, or a lower lingual arch when it's used in the lower arches,
it's usually used to hold this transverse dimension steady.
So this one's never really used as a palatal expander, I just wanted to include it here
because it can be used that way, but it's usually used for preserving transverse anchorage,
which is a fancy way of saying holding that transverse dimension steady.
It can be activated so it can be squeezed together and bonded in there at that activated position.
It can also be used for some limited dental constriction as well if you do it the opposite
way, although this is going to be just some very limited dental tipping.
So again, this is usually used to preserve your transverse dimension.
All right, now for some mixed dentition appliances.
Some things that we use primarily in the mixed dentition phase.
All right, so the NANCE appliance is a very controversial appliance.
Some people swear by it and others swear that it doesn't do a thing.
And the idea here is that you have an acrylic button that sits against the palette with wires
that run back to bands around the molars.
And this is supposed to hold the AP position of those upper molars and prevent them from
slipping forward.
So this could be used as a space maintainer if you have premature loss of a bunch of
upper teeth, or it can be used during orthodontic treatment when closing space.
If you want to hold those molars back and again prevent them from slipping forward.
So this is something you could use to reinforce anchorage in a maximum anchorage case.
Although again, some people, not a huge fan of this appliance.
The lower lingual holding arch is something we've talked about before.
It's similar to the NANCE, but it's used in the lower arch.
However, there's no place to put an acrylic button down here at the floor of the mouth.
So instead, a wire is placed against the lingual surfaces of the incisors.
Now this is actually a lot more effective because we have a hard stopping point instead
of this bouncy, palatal soft tissue.
So we would prefer, honestly, to use something like this in the upper arch.
The problem is, if we did, and we had a wire running along here, well, the lower teeth
would likely bite into it, and that would be a problem in and of itself.
So you're usually stuck with the NANCE in the upper arch, and we like to use a lower
lingual holding arch in the lower arch.
Anyway, the LLHA is used to preserve arch length by preventing mesial drift of those lower
molars and lingual tipping of those lower incisors during the transition from the mixed
to the permanent dentition, and its main purpose is to hold open that leeway space.
Again, it could be used in certain situations for some kind of maximum anchorage scenario.
It's designed to sit passively, but it can be activated if you want to tip those lower
incisors forward, for example.
The lip bumper is a cool little appliance where this heavy arch wire, or I should say
heavy labial wire, is inserted into buckle tubes on the mandibular first molars, and
this acrylic pad rests against the lower lip.
So the lower lip transmits this force against the acrylic pad, and it tips these back molars
distally, or backwards.
But not only that, it also allows those lower front teeth to lean forward, because we no
longer have lip pressure from the mentalis pushing against those incisors.
So a good way to summarize how this works is the lip bumper transmits lower lip pressure
to the molars, tipping them back, and it relieves lower lip pressure from the incisors, allowing
them to tip forward.
So it's creating space in both directions.
As far as permanent dentition appliances, there's a lot more out there, but these are
two big categories, aligners and braces.
So aligners are clear and removable, and they involve a series of trays that are manufactured
according to a prescription that's developed by the provider using some kind of algorithm
or software, and they're worn by the patient in a certain sequence.
And so bonded attachments are often required to aid in specific tooth movements.
And so if you have this clear plastic tray, sometimes a tooth is small or it's smooth,
and there's not a whole lot for the plastic to grab onto, and that tooth won't move in
the way we want.
So sometimes we have to bond attachments, little blocks of composite onto a tooth to create
a tooth handle that the plastic can grab onto and help to move that tooth.
Then of course we have braces, which is what everyone thinks of when they think of orthodontics,
can also be called fixed appliances.
The earliest we can use braces is usually with the eruption of the permanent first molars,
and the ideal for a comprehensive case is in the late mixed dentition or even better
when all the permanent teeth have erupted.
In contemporary orthodontics, all of the teeth, including the molars, can be bonded with these
cool little brackets.
They used to put big metal bands around every single tooth, and now we have these neat little
brackets, and there's a whole bunch of different prescriptions of them.
There's MBT, Roth, Andrews, and all of that is way outside the scope of the board exam,
but just to give you an idea of a few of the different variations that are out there.
So for applying brackets to the teeth, there's a set protocol that we usually follow.
The first thing is to clean off the enamel using pumice or a cotton roll to remove the
pelicle in any plaque that might be on that tooth.
We etch the center of the clinical crown on that facial surface to allow for micro-mechanical
bonding.
This may sound familiar from our operative topics.
Then we apply prime, which conditions the enamel, and will chemically bond to the composite
resin, which is placed onto the base of the bracket.
That's actually what's fixing it to the tooth surface.
So once that composite is placed on the bracket, the bracket is pushed onto the tooth and it's
centered at the center of the facial surface of the clinical crown, and then it's cured
with that blue light in order to polymerize the composite and fix the bracket in place.
So a big decision in orthodontic treatment planning is do we need to take any teeth out?
That often comes down to, is there enough room in the arch for all the teeth to fit?
But honestly, there's a whole lot more that goes into that decision.
So we lean towards non-extraction.
If the patient has minimal crowning or maybe even spacing available, if they have a deep
bite tendency, because non-extraction actually tends to open a bite up.
If they have flat retrusive lips, it also might make sense to do a non-extraction treatment
plan, because another way to think of non-extraction is expansion, or expanding the arch outward
and forward, and that can help to improve the soft tissue profile if they have flat
retrusive lips, same with obtuse nasolabial angle.
On the other side, we tend towards extraction if the patient has severe crowning.
They may not have enough room in the arch to fit all the teeth.
If they have minimal overbite or even open bite, so the opposite is true here, if we
extract teeth that tends to deepen the bite.
If they have full, pertrusive lips, perhaps we don't want to expand the arches even more,
same with acute nasolabial angle.
If they have anterior recession or minimal or thin attached gingival tissue, we probably
don't want to stress the peridontal apparatus even more by pushing all those incisors even
more forward.
And if we're camouflaging a skeletal class 2 or class 3, we might take out teeth only
in one arch to help hide that underlying skeletal discrepancy.
In terms of comprehensive braces treatment, we typically think of our treatment plans
in 3 stages.
First is alignment and leveling.
That's getting the teeth straight, leveling the curve of speed, improving overbite.
Next we work on the molar relationship for AP correction and also close any space that
might be from extractions or already existent space.
And so a lot of this is done with chains and rubber bands, maybe if we're doing growth
modification, we might use a hertz appliance, things like that.
And finally finishing and detailing, this involves a lot of root tip correction, so roots
need to be paralleled to improve stability and peridontal health.
And certain anterior teeth might look a little bit off in the smile, and so this is where
we get really picky and finish the case.
And finally for adult treatment, adults are more likely to request ceramic, lingual or
invisible braces, that just means aligners.
For a more aesthetic treatment, any peridontal conditions must be stabilized before beginning
orthodontic treatment.
That's really important because orthodontic tooth movement, like we've learned, is a
controlled inflammatory response, and if we have something like peridontal disease that's
uncontrolled inflammation, well that could really mess up what we're trying to do.
Steel ligatures retain less plaque than elastomeric ligatures, that might be a good consideration
for someone with not the best oral hygiene.
And finally, we can't do growth modification because there's no active growth and the growth
spurt is over.
So all inter-arch correction must be accomplished, mentally or surgically, since adults do not
have the benefit of modifying their growth during treatment.
So that's it for this video guys, thank you so much for watching and thanks for sticking
with it because I know this will be a long video because we covered a lot of different
treatment appliances.
I tried not to get too into the weeds with this and tried to keep with a more of an overview
of the most important high yield facts for each of those appliances.
So please like this video if you enjoyed it and subscribe to this channel for much more
on dentistry.
If you're interested in supporting this channel and what I do, please check out my Patreon page.
Thank you to all of my patrons here for their support.
You can unlock things like access to my video slides to take notes on and practice questions
for the board exams.
So go check that out, the link is in the description.
Thanks again for watching everyone and I'll see you in the next video.